نفق مفتوح في مكان ما في قطاع
غزة يرشدنا مقاتلو الجهاد الإسلامي
إلى أن يكون الجو حارًا ورطبًا وضيقًا ومنخفضًا ،
مما يجعله يشعر برهاب الأماكن المغلقة حيث
يمكنك أن ترى أن العديد من هذه الأنفاق
معززة بالخرسانة لحمايتها
من الانهيار ولكن أيضًا من
الضربات الجوية الإسرائيلية المحتملة  لهما اسم مختلف
عن الأنفاق الإرهابية السيد.  اللعنة مادلين ،
حسنًا ، أنا قطة أثينا
هذا شيء آخر إذا
استأنفت ستكون محظوظًا من هنا
، فقد أثبتوا أيضًا فعاليتهم في
تهريب الأسلحة وشن الهجمات
إلى إسرائيل. أبو عبد الله يعطي
المقاتلين حديثًا حماسيًا
يخبرهم ألا يكونوا كذلك  خائفون الله
معهم تخضع حركات اليوم لرقابة
مشددة وصول الصحفيين من
النادر
أن يعصبوا أعيننا ونحن نستعد
للذهاب إلى الموقع التالي
الجهاد الإسلامي هو جزء من المجتمع المعقد
القائم على الفصائل وهو غزة أصغر
من حركة حماس المسلحة.  المجموعة التي
تدير القطاع ولكن في أواخر الشهر الماضي
أطلقت حركة الجهاد الإسلامي أكبر
تبادل لإطلاق النار فوق غزة منذ أربع
سنوات ، قصفت إسرائيل 60 هدفًا
ردًا على حوالي 100 صاروخ وقذيفة
هاون أطلقت من مواقع إطلاق مثل
هذه ، لذلك أخبرني أن نظام الأسلحة هذا
موجود هنا  مدى يتراوح بين 4 و
6 كيلومترات تم استخدامه مؤخرًا
ضد إسرائيل. يقول أبو عبد الله إن
الهجوم كان انتقامًا لمقتل
العشرات من المتظاهرين الفلسطينيين  قتل
جنود إسرائيليون على يد جنود إسرائيليين على حدود غزة مع إسرائيل
الله بورليسون نتنياهو ،
كيف أن شانيل جديدة من البازلت في
ألبرتا وهونام ، هل أنت بخير ، دانا
مسلحة جيدًا دانا المجنونة ، قرأنا
كوراما القريب جاء بشار صغير رائع عندما
يكون لديك على الرغم من ذلك  الله القرآن لله ،
كنت أتحدث عن رحلة
ولكن قذيفة واحدة أصابت روضة أطفال في
إسرائيل ولم يصب أحد بأذى ولكن فقط لأنه
لم يكن هناك أحد في
الجوار ، سألت أبو عبد الله لماذا يستهدفون المدنيين الإسرائيليين ونعم تيفيلين ثم موكونا يحتاج العالم إلى معرفته
أن المقاومة لم تخطط أبدًا لاستهداف
الأطفال ، وهو يعترف لي بأن الأخطاء قد
ارتكبت ، ومع ذلك ، مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
يطلقون الصواريخ بشكل
عشوائي ، تصنف الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل والاتحاد الأوروبي
الجهاد الإسلامي مثل حماس
كمنظمة إرهابية
، وليس للجماعة أصدقاء في الخارج ، لكنها ليست كذلك.
معدل تكرار معزول تمامًا لكربون
اللاما الأمريكي المتأنق يخرج حبة أخرى لسيارة
ليموزين إيرانية معترف بها في جميع الكتيبات تقريبًا
الأكثر تدينًا  شاي جيد صادق
أورياني يكون بيدويا فيدل بالتساوي على الشاطئ
كلما كانت سوريا أفضل الشرير الذي يتسبب في
مأساة يمكن وصفها بمجموعة من
الطرق المختلفة التي تجعل الجماعات المسلحة
المسؤولة ملتزمة بتدمير إسرائيل
هي مجرد واحدة من العديد ولكن طالما أن
إسرائيل ومصر تحافظان على  قبضة حديدية
من الخارج وبقية العالم
يرن يديه من الصعب أن ترى كيف
سيتغير أي شيء إيان لي CNN غزة